la première bagnole qui l'a touché à
quel âge il est touché très très tôt
j'avais une enfin je vais pas toucher je
la volée à mon père j'avais une douzaine
d'années est d'accord c'était quoi comme
caisse une cinq chevaux au site run 1 et
alors si vous êtes jeune foutu colisée
normalement ah non je ne venais je n'ai
su que conduira normalement ah ouais
vraiment à 10 kilomètres heure un disque
1 sauf un mais moi ce n'était jamais
assez vite
bon est ce que tu es ce que tu es
d'accord vont me faire peur
j arriverai chatman on attend jusqu'à
présent on se présente à on se présente
à 3 m à 2 m du genre c'est un truc qui
fait le plus peur quand je vais voir là
aussi on s'est arrêté au bord de la
rivière
non non non non on va sauver il peut y
avoir une rupture d'organes qui fait que
qui fasse que tout d'un coup bignon se
retrouve dans le temps
c'est déjà quand tu es dans l'eau avec
une voiture c'est déjà arrivé ça oui
quand j'essaie d'ouvrir les portes on
peut les ouvrir facilement dollars mais
s'ils n'ouvrent pas on n'ouvre pas non
c'est pas ouvrir non non ça j'avoue tu
sors tenté dans l'eau il faut se laisser
complètement remplir la voiture de ma
motivation importance moi je me suis
toujours demandé ce qui se passait
qu'est ce qui se passe alors il faut
laisser la voiture se remplir d'eau et
après ouais on peut ouvrir soit une
portière soit d'accord et tu sors oui
oui d'accord tu nages quoi il faut pas
essayer de sortir avant que la voiture
sera surtout pas parce que la synchro
oui parce que on sait que je suis rincé
puisse complètement et alors la panique
gagne stress etc
alors là c'est foutu ça c'est un truc de
cauchemar on est dans l'eau s'il est un
trou on se dit qu'est ce que je vais
faire d'accord mais tu conduis quoi dans
la journée ma voiture personnelle
c'est une peugeot ou une turbo 16 ah
ouais tu conduis gentiment ah oui très
là
et bien voilà et le truc le plus cinglé
que tu as fait c'est quoi effectuer tout
ça je souhaitais tout a vraiment eu très
peur je me suis je me suis fait peur à
jour en finlande et je sautais près 120
kilomètres à l'heure
voiture sur un ferry boat quittait
l'hôtel à bond de 20 mètres à faire pour
atterrir sur un premier ferry boat la
presse je continuerai ma roue avec
l'élan je sautais sur un deuxième mais
mais conjoncture défavorable
la suspension s'est cassé à la réception
du premier saut et je n'ai pas pu
aligner le tremplin et donc j'ai manqué
de vitesse année avec entre la voiture
sur l'anglin et j'ai pris le bord du
ferry boat comme ça ça découpe et ma
voiture comme une boîte de conserve à
l'intérieur j'avais un ballon censé me
tenir flottant en cas de problème et
comme ça et découpé la voiture le ballon
qui n'était pas attaché erreur ne va pas
est sorti et la voiture commençait à
couler
quand je parle de conjoncture
défavorable c'est là où j'ai failli
paniquer mais j'avais des arceaux
j'avais un rôle bas et mon pied est
resté coincé dans le rôle bas c'est donc
comme michel y avait 90 matsu contre 3
alors heureusement il y avait des
pompiers de turku en finlande et mac
formidable on avait briefé avant c'était
fait vraiment un briefing d'enfer et il
connaissait vraiment où ils sont venus
in extremis pour me retirer dans ma
position fâcheuse
là j'ai vraiment eu vraiment eu chaud
aux miches 1 là je me suis vue c'est
l'une des fois et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus